so I just have to ask because
everybody's huge fan of Star Wars do you
have any kind of tease I know you can't
like say too much but um uh it is
[Laughter]
happening solid
M um I know the I know the general story
yeah which is very cool it's been a
minute though since you've done
something like it's been like how long
since the last well what's crazy is time
passing it was like 11 years ago when I
got cast
yeah a baby you're still a baby says
your skin you're welcome from genetics
yeah yeah um yeah so it's been and then
it's been yeah quite a few years since
I've been part of the that kind of cool
to jump back in the role like that many
years later right yeah and also strange
cuz I was the baby and now I'm like oh
I'm going to go in as like you know I
like got married and done other stuff
and like I feel more like a grownup now
yeah um so I'm real woman yeah I like it
I'm excited everybody's you have so many
projects and you said the one I want to
mention real quick you said is it Magpie
Magpie yes so you're working on and
that's the one you did with your husband
yes that is premiering at South by
Southwest in March oh awesome very cool
all the things in the air you're
floating all the things uh let's take
another break everybody Daisy's movie
Sometimes I think about dying is it's
just a fun title to say it's in theaters
now be sure to check it
[Music]
out
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home